we can get more on the situation on the
ground now and in the studio i'm joined
by defense analyst at the royal united
services institute dr alex walmsley
hello again alex a lot of the flash
points and a lot of the focus of the
russian forces of course there along the
eastern side there what is the latest
situation well the latest is despite the
greatest russian attempts the ukrainian
resistance is holding very firm
and the russians have not made any
significant progress along that eastern
flank
the talk however today was meant to see
the humanitarian corridor from mariopol
to zapurigia
and by all accounts that ceasefire is
not holding there is shelling of the
steel works and of mario paul as we
speak uh which means that that the
russians are not sticking to what they
had claimed they were going to do yeah
because they had claimed they were going
to leave that steel works alone right
they weren't they were not going to let
anyone out but they were not going to
continue their assaults exactly they
were going to concentrate their attack
on the the eastern side of russia and
start pushing towards odessa to the west
uh but but that does seem to not be the
case as we speak now the world has been
watching what has been going on in that
city there haven't they and we've got
new satellite images which paint quite a
frightening picture talk us through them
this is this is the reality of modern
satellite imagery that it's very hard to
hide things so we have this image taken
originally on i think about the 22nd of
march showing an old cemetery
but then the most recent imagery that
we've seen today which i think was taken
about a week ago you see this new
excavated area in the in the corner
which does the ukrainians say
appear to be the site of a mass grave
with as many as 10 000 people
incarcerated in it okay so they're going
to be investigations into what that
actually is it is a blurry image but it
does tell us that something has changed
there exactly and russia's talking about
its second
phase
not being described anymore as a
liberation operation but it seems to be
very intent on annexation
what exactly does that second phase
entail and what does it mean for moldova
it doesn't look great for moldova
putin wants to demonstrate some sort of
success by may 9th which is a
significant date in russian history and
so he is pushing towards past odessa to
moldova where there is a region the
transnistria region which is
self-proclaimed russian separatists um
and that that he's using the same
language as he used at the beginning of
the ukraine offensive to talk about
genocide and discrimination of people
and coming to liberate people liberation
as the ukrainians will know is is a is a
scary word from a russian perspective
because he's claiming mario paul has
been liberated and we can all see the
city has been flattened so if i were
moldova i would be very wary of this
oncoming russian assault okay all right
some distances though to cover
to get there but we are of course
keeping an eye on it uh with help from
our clever analysts here in the studio